I want to do a quick correction to the AIME problem
where we cut out a wedge of a log in that problem.
So we had a wedge
so just to remind ourselves that we had a log
and it looked like that
we made one cut that was right along
that was perpendicular to the axis of the log
and we made another cut
that had a 45 degree angle.
So it was like that.
And the solution to the problem
we had to figure out the volume of the wedge
and the big trick there was
if I drew the wedge like this
so let me take a side view of the wedge.
So this is the side of the wedge right over here.
I could shade it to show that it's kind of round.
So if I were to shade it
you could kind of see that it is round.
So this is a side view of the wedge.
We knew that this right here is a 45 degree angle.
And the way that we solved the problem
or the kind of trick was to say
Hey, if we had another wedge like this
and we just stacked it on top of this one
if we just flipped it over and made it like this
then we also have a 45 degree angle over here
and it would make a cylinder
and it's very easy
to figure out the height of a cylinder.
And I misspoke when I said it was lucky
that we had a 45 degree angle.
Because in the last video
I was actually visualizing it incorrectly.
Because I said if you had anything
less than a 45 degree angle
this wouldn't have worked out properly
But I was wrong!
It would have worked out properly.
Let me show you.
So this, let's just say whatever angle you have here.
So this is going to be 90 degrees over here.
Whatever angle you have over here
so let's call that theta
this over here, they have to add up to 180.
So theta plus 90 plus this has to be 180
Or theta plus this has to be 90
or you could just call this 90 minus theta.
Now, if I were to take the same thing
if I took another kind of wedge like this
and flipped it over this thing
it's not this angle that's going to be right here
it's this angle.
Let me just draw it over here.
It would look like this.
Where this now is theta.
This end right here
is actually that end on the flipped version.
And now this angle right over here
is now 90 minus theta.
So clearly you have 90 minus theta plus theta.
So this thing is going to be a right angle
no matter what.
Obviously it has to be a reasonable angle
but no matter
assuming that its less than 90 degrees
it would have worked out.
You could have done the same trick.
Anyway, hopefully that clarifies it
and I apologize
for the incorrect visualization in the last video.